good morning John it's Friday do you
remember a couple of weeks ago when we
got together and raised 1.6 million
dollars for charity during the project
for awesome and we were joined by a
bunch of amazing people on our
livestream and we voted on what
charities would get money and we made
videos to promote charities maybe we've
lost it maybe we've forgotten it some
maybe that wonderful feeling isn't
something you can have all the time but
maybe you can have it just a little bit
right now in case you've forgotten some
of what went down or maybe you weren't
there for the whole thing that guy
was it was anyone cuz that's all that's
it that's dedication John it's time for
that it's recap time look if the project
for awesome it's it's raw it's real it's
got a butt crack in it do the thing
where let me see the finished result
welcome to the project does anyone have
any updates on the agnes situation final
hat i'm just happy to be alive and
speaking to humans can you explain the
sheep look at a squishy face what's
under my pants what does it mean
[Music]
I learned a lot I love you as high as I
can reach said the from up from house if
an episode is challenging or if a topic
is challenging it inspires me to keep
working on it because I'm like this
means that something here is worth
talking about if it's hard give me that
or not
forgive me Dad not really for sitting
it's more of a standing costume
you owe me getting an adult in there for
you we've got two I mean three adults if
you count me
I like how you didn't though originally
I'm a damn person I can do this all day
everybody is this gonna be okay
he took the lawyers my brain is a
sausage good daddy likes a heart crime
big daddy likes pork rinds huge thanks
to everybody again for being part of the
2018 project for awesome here in the
livestream we're having a great time and
there appears to have been a development
I wish that Alice were here right now to
see what proper face painting looks like
oh my gosh
gumball Mike is the first dinosaur on
the moon right yes fight them you know
this is what I've always wanted is just
to watch a grown man save a problem like
global health goons feel like spitting
on a wildfire but it's not like all the
resources all the power that you're able
to to like exert on the world like that
has real-world effects sorry you made me
cry this has been a beautiful time I'm
so happy everyone in nerdfighteria thank
you and as they say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome thank you to
Nicole Sweeney for editing this video
with me she's like 90% 95% of the bat
probably more % of the work than that
and thank you of course to all of the
project for awesome z' donors and
volunteers and video makers and guests
and champions and to all the nonprofit
organizations that are making the world
a better place with their hard work
thank you John
I will see you on Tuesday